Colombia comenzará un segundo proceso de
paz el presidente Gustavo Petro anunció
este lunes una mesa de diálogo con el
Estado Mayor central una de las
disidencias de las antiguas FARC que es
liderada por alias Iván mordisco con
esta posibilidad que inicia en el día de
hoy
da la actitud del fiscal de aceptar los
nombres de las personas que actuaran
como voceros de esa agrupación
Prácticamente la mitad de las personas
armadas hoy
entran a un proceso de paz con el
gobierno para que este proceso pueda
llevarse a cabo la fiscalía general de
Colombia suspendió 19 órdenes de captura
por pedido del gobierno para él
esas esa organización es una
organización que tiene isla dota de un
carácter político para negociar acuerdos
de paz con el gobierno nacional en
franjas 24 Jorge mantilla investigador
en asuntos de conflicto y crimen
organizado explicó las posibles
dificultades que surgir en las
conversaciones entre el gobierno y el
Estado Mayor central
el Gobierno ya ha reconocido
explícitamente al Estado Mayor central
como un grupo de carácter político los
retos tienen que ver justamente que esta
Estructura No es un grupo propiamente
unificado hay más de 25 frentes dentro
de lo que se denomina Estado Mayor
central gran parte de las dudas tienen
que ver con si hay unidad de mando si
efectivamente son un interlocutor que
tenga unos criterios claros para
negociar Además del Estado Mayor central
el estado colombiano apunta a tener
acercamientos en las próximas semanas
con la segunda marquetalia otra de las
disidencias de las fa